hi everybody um my name is John
Quackenbush and uh welcome to my bio
conference live presentation um I was
asked to describe uh some of the work
that I and my colleagues have been doing
in the the realm of really building a
program in personalized medicine and um
when we look at personalized medicine
one of the things we've come to
recognize is that there are two pieces
to the puzzle that we're trying to solve
one is uh a piece of the puzzle that
really deals with the delivery of
personalized medicine services and care
and that in the practice of medicine um
the requirements are very very different
from those in research that what
Physicians are looking for even with
large scale genomic data is they have
that data distilled down to some
something which is easily interpretable
and actionable so well we might be able
to sequence an entire genome but most of
what they want to see is information
that they can use in a short period of
time to make a diagnostic or prognostic
decision now those aren't the kinds of
um applications of personalized medicine
and genomic medicine that uh we really
see written up in the newspapers what we
tend to see are the applications where
someone sequences um a child with a rare
disease going through a diagnostic
Odyssey and a group of people will sit
together um in a room and try to make
sense of what's in the genome um and
that's a really exciting application of
genomics in medicine but it's not the
one with potentially the greatest impact
the one that's going to have um an
influence on how a large number of
people are treated um but both of those
really fall sort of into the domain of
of delivering health care and delivering
medical information that is informed by
gen Els but how we get to the
understanding we need to make either um
some kind of strong conclusion based on
uh diagnostic evidence or how we tie
together different pieces of information
to distill out something report to
Physicians is still really driven by uh
research and so what I've been thinking
about a lot in the work that I've been
doing um over the last few years is
really thinking how we build a program
in personalized medicine and focused on
research and that's what I'm going to
talk to you about today so I should at
least start with some disclosures um
it's important to at least note that I'm
on scientific advisory boards for a
number of different companies um and
also that U and this may not be
surprising to some of you I and a
colleague uh founded uh personalized
medicine company uh really um focused on
delivering software Solutions and tools
to support personalized medicine in
research uh in the practice of clinical
medicine and uh supporting patients and
patient
communities um however I'm not going to
present any of that work here uh nothing
done any of those companies uh really
what I'm going to do is tell you about
my experience uh based on uh working at
The Dana farer Cancer Institute and
really thinking about how we would um
develop uh personalized medicine
Solutions here
to drive research forward so one of the
things I like to do in uh presenting
work is to use quotes uh my background
is actually in physics and so U maybe
not surprisingly I have a quote from a
physicist Jules poner uh P said science
is built with facts as a house is with
stones but a collection of facts is no
more a science than a heap of stones is
a house and for me I really like this
quote because it crystallizes some of
the challenges in doing uh genomics and
omic medicine in the sense that what
we're able to do now in a really
profound way is generate absolutely
tremendous quantities of data um and the
challenge is to take that heap of stones
that huge pile of data and to put it
into some kind of framework so that we
can make sense of it and so the way I
like to think of our challeng is the
challenge is taking data and turning
into knowledge and knowledge into
understanding when I think about this I
actually have another quote from myself
use and about today I don't know where I
lost you but what I'll tell you about
today is a story of um really describing
how we've thought about the the whole
problem of implementing personalized
medicine so uh one of the things I've
done over the course of my career is
worked with genomic data in the context
of understanding human disease and one
of the really fascinating things about
it is over the last few years we've been
able to think very critically about how
we apply genomics to really look at the
entire life cycle
of now go all right so um until we have
those technical problems um what I was
hoping to tell you was that we've really
thought about how we use genomics to
address the entire life cycle of disease
from doing a better job of estimating uh
genetic risk to doing better early
detection of disease patient
stratification disease staging selecting
really with the goal of selecting the
appropriate treatment option for each
patient and our goal in doing that is to
really best U improve the overall
survival and the quality of life of our
patients I think one of the things that
we've seen time and again is that our
patients want exactly the same sort of
thing that we all want well we all know
that one day we're going to die we just
want that to be as far off in the future
and as pleasant as possible so really
our goal um in in trying to build a
program in personalized genomic medicine
is to think about how we assemble the
tools we need to address each step in
this life life cycle of disease and
largely uh the the tool that we've had
available to do this has been
um array based uh Technologies for
generating genomic data that we can then
use uh to really uh ask questions about
each one of these individual stages and
what's exciting today is that uh these
arrays are increasingly being replaced
by um sequencing based technologies that
have the potential to generate uh much
more complex much more interesting data
types and data sets that we can use to
begin to look at an integrated um
interpretation of disease so um in order
to do this what you really have to do is
think about various steps in the process
and I'm going to outl them outline them
here and then talk about each one of
these uh the first thing you have to do
is think about assuring that you have
access to samples in some kind of
rational consent because really it's
patient samples that feed the entire
process you have to develop a technology
platform and um a few years years ago
when I was giving versions of this talk
people would ask me what sequencer they
should buy uh that the answer to that
question is almost uh irrelevant today
uh all of these Technologies generate
one and only one thing and that's data
um and whether you choose to do this
internally or to Outsource data
generation really that choice of
Technology platform is one that has to
deliver you data so that you can start
thinking about really putting the other
key elements in place um in order to to
do that and put those elements in place
what you have to think about is
information integration um genomic data
is really wonderful but the only way to
interpret it and make sense of it is in
context so you know I'm um uh a pretty
healthy normal individual if you were to
sequence my genome you could learn about
my gender which you probably already
know uh my ethnicity uh which uh I could
probably make a reasonable guess um
about I could tell you if I have sticky
ear wax but there's a really inex Sensi
little finger test you can use uh to
determine that but um if I were to look
at my genome uh in the context of
disease I might actually be able to say
something that's relevant so um if I had
um uh a cardiovascular disease and my
physician was going to treat me with
warrin what you could do um is uh look
at my cytochrome p450 oxidase Gene and
determine uh whether or not I was likely
to respond to Warr and if so what the
appropriate ads would be so that
information integration is absolutely
critical to put information in content
once you do this especially in a
research setting you think about you
have to think about how you present that
data and information to the local
community and what I mean by that is the
research Community there's tremendous
interest in consuming genomic data what
we really want to be in a position to do
is to consume it effectively um and um
what that means is that we have to allow
not only computational biologists and
biostatisticians to have access to the
data but we have to make it broadly
accessible that's part of really this
overall process of as a computational
scientist or computational biologist
enabling research beyond your own uh you
then have to think about how you engage
corporate Partners to really make
information broadly accessible um and to
really get the best of read tools and a
lot of that uh really comes down to put
putting the data and information in a
format that allows you to do research
and being a research scientist at heart
I'm going to tell you a little about
some of the work that we've been doing
and then the last piece of the puzzle is
really communicating information to the
broader community and the reason that we
want to do that is that we want to take
the data and information that we have
available and we want to assure uh that
uh we explain to um the
non-scientists why the research we're
doing is so important because for them
part of the process is contributing back
by consenting to be in studies so I'm
going to go through these and go through
some of these uh fairly quickly uh
especially since we burned some time
dealing with technical difficulties uh
but uh I think each one of these is
important and often people say well you
know you're a computational biologist At
Heart John why are you interested in
access to samples and for me it's it's
really dealing with the entire ecosystem
that you need to put in place to be able
to do the kind of work that I'm most
interested in doing so access to samples
is really tied to some questions that
are really profound that actually have
at their heart uh an IT component to
them uh what we really like to be in a
position to do is to get patients into
the process of being Partners in
understanding disease and so what we
really want to try to do is to get them
involved and if you talk to patients I
mean patients come and visit our lab all
the time I've had patients call me and
asked if they could contribute their
genomes to have the genome sequence
because they want disease better
understood uh so they really want to be
part of this process but what we have to
do to get them involved is actually
develop an informed consent and that
informed consent has to be structured in
such a way that we allow patients to be
partners in the research process but
there are regulations um in play in the
US um in particular Hippa the health
insurance portability and protection act
and what that requires that we do as
part of the process is generate an
informed consent but also that we assure
patient
confidentiality and this is actually a
challenge in a genomic era because
genome sequence in and of itself is
fundamentally identifiable in fact as
little as 10 or 20 steps can be used to
uniquely identify an individual and if I
have about 250,000 base pairs of genomic
DNA a tiny fract of the entire genome
there are enough variant positions that
I could identify each and every one of
the two or three people hopefully
hundreds of people who are listening to
me today um and so that data has to be
secured and what that really means is
the whole idea of deidentification sort
of goes out the window and we have to
think very differently about data
security so in building computational
tools for managing this data uh we
really have to think about data security
data encryption a whole set of things
that most of us in the day-to-day
practice of our research don't consider
and and that really reflects the the
idea that
identifiability has become a moving
Target that what we want to know is
whether or not um we can really secure
the individual information about an
individual patient yet make it
accessible in the context uh for
research so
this is is becoming an increasing
challenge with the Thousand genome in
the age of Facebook what this means um
has really become unclear I have a son
he's about seven and a half years old
and I can almost guarantee that by the
time he's 15 years old his genome is
going to be sequenced I just don't want
his genome to appear on Facebook right I
want him to have access and control over
who sees that data and for what purposes
but you know the thing I recognized is
that younger Generations have a very
different view of privacy that uh my
nephew is 21 years old he's an
undergraduate student right now and I
can look at his Facebook page and so can
his mom and she can see things that he's
doing that I wouldn't tell my mother
today that I did when I was in college
I'm not saying I didn't do a lot of the
same things he's doing but who I share
it with and when I shared it was uh uh
very very different uh than you know the
way he's approaching privacy and so we
really have to think about privacy and
confidentiality but we have to
understand that societal pressures and
Norms about this data are changing and
so we really need patients to be
involved in this process but most
patients will tell you that if they have
disease they don't care who sees their
genome we have to then inform them that
their genome is also partially their
siblings their parents um their cousins
their children's genomes and so this is
really a challenge and genomics has
become a disruptive technology in how we
think about this entire process of
confidentiality I mentioned you have to
uh develop a technology platform that
technology platform is really uh uh
driven by our observation that the cost
of genome sequencing is falling and
falling dramatically so this is a cost
curve from the national Human Genome
Research Institute um this um data in
fact reflects um information that's
available on their website I just
reposted it or re um uh plotted it using
Excel and if you're quantitative nerd
like me what you'd probably like to do
is to look at that data and fit a curve
to it and if you do that do regression
analysis on this you realize it's kind
of ridiculous that you don't have one
curve you actually have two curves you
have the old Sanger sequencing curve and
then you have this second generation of
sequencing Technologies and I I hesitate
to call it next Generation because my
immed Med question when son calls it
next generation is what's next um and
I'm not really sure what that's going to
be if it's going to be next next or next
next next so we have the second
generation the clearly third and fourth
generation Technologies coming online
but what's interesting about it is as
you look at this yellow curve what you
realize is that the cost of sequencing a
genome started dropping dramatically in
about uh late 2008 early 2009 uh late 20
early 2009 and if you look at the data
the cost of sequencing genomes for the
longest time was falling by about 33%
per quarter and um you know that's a
that's sort of a trend that's a little
difficult to get a handle on but the way
I think about it is if I were to started
sequencing my genome in 2009 about um uh
three and a half four and a half years
ago if I were to sequence my genome then
in order to do that I would have to
mortgage my house and today sequencing a
genome cost only a few thousand and I
could put that genome on my credit card
and that fundamentally changes the way
we think about genomic data in the
context of Health and Wellness in the
context of research in the context of
disease and so um if we look at the cost
curve the cost curve has actually
leveled off a little bit but when I
stopped making this um graph in 2011
adding data to it I made predictions and
one of them is that we would hit the
,000 genome in October of 201 12 many of
you may have realized that didn't happen
but in fact we can generate a research
grade genome for about two and a half or
$3,000 and we can generate a clinical
grade geome for about twice that maybe a
little more but what's more important is
that what we can interpret in most
genomic sequence is just what's in the
coding region so we can do an exom um uh
sequence for $1,000 or less and in fact
do that in great enough depth that we
could probably use it clinically but
where we see most of the applications is
in targeted panels where we can sequence
the thousandfold depth for a few hundred
doll so genomic medicine is actually
here and here to stay if you look at
this regression curve and look further
you H the $1,000 the $100 genome
sometime next year is that going to
happen probably not but I I will bet you
within two years we're at the place at
the point we're sequencing genomes
either with modifications of existing
Technologies or new technologies is
going be extraordinarily inexpensive and
really uh that they start that kind of U
application starts to make its way into
the routine practice of medicine so in
2010 we got an alumina high seek
instrument in our lab um and um pretty
quickly we got to the point where we
could sequence genomes for uh less than
$10,000 this was an instrument announced
last year the ion torn proton their
promis when they announced it was a TW a
$1,000 genome in 24 hours or less the
truth is we never got there uh but um
you know this put a lot of pressure on
uh the cost of genome sequencing and um
there are more technologies that are in
play uh this was uh the Oxford nanor
mini iion which was announced with great
Fanfare at the beginning of uh
2012 uh the promise was a genome uh
through a USB um insert disposable
sequencer using manif
Technologies in minutes for hundreds of
dollars uh whether or not we actually
get to the point where this technology
really becomes a a real and viable
commercial um product remains to be seen
but I can tell you I've talked to
representatives of many different
sequencing companies and that there are
a large number of companies out there
developing applications that really have
the potential uh to
revolutionize um DNA sequence data
generation so the challenge is that
these new technologies have been
transforming biomedical research from
what was largely a laboratory science
into what's increasingly in information
science what we need are new approaches
to making sense of the data we generate
and the winners and losers in the race
to really understand disease are going
to be those best able to collect manage
analyze and interpret the underlying
data so what we've recognized we have to
do is really focus on those questions by
making information integration a central
mission of almost everything we do
so uh I want to point out that um I was
recognized along with some of my
colleagues um at a ceremony at the White
House here in the US uh for uh something
they called the open science champions
of change and um it was a really nice
ceremony there are a lot of people you
may recognize here uh from uh the
genomics world uh along with a few other
non- genomic people who are an
recognized but what was really important
about this uh at least from my
perspective is that this was a forum
where people were talking about big data
and big data is the buzzword everybody
throws around all the time in fact when
you really think about it big data is
not a Panacea for all the challenges we
face it's really the data in the context
of the
metadata and um one of the things I
emphasized when I did a presentation at
this ceremony was that the metadata is
everything that if if we just generate
genomic sequence we're not going to
learn anything unless unless we place
that into context something I've
mentioned earlier so we've really
started thinking about this overall
challenge of how we take clinical data
and multiomic data and use it to make
sense of disease to ask questions about
the nature of disease and one of the
things we realized we needed to be able
to do that was to gather the data
together and what we see almost
everywhere I've been is that we have
Legacy systems in place collecting
Clinic iCal data and in many places omic
data is simply stored on Unix file
systems in some core facility and that
in order to bring data together there's
no really eable Sol easy and workable
solution so what we proposed when we
were actually faced with this challenge
now about seven years ago is that um the
only way to sort of solve this problem
was to bring the data together into a
central warehouse and then once we did
that we could actually link the data and
information together with information in
the public domain and ongoing um uh
projects like clinical trials to really
drive the kind of research questions we
wanted to be able to ask so this was an
essential part uh of really thinking
about building an infrastructure for
genomic medicine and one of the things
that we focused on earliest in the
process so we collected and gathered
this information together and what we
did was we gathered it and and used it
commercially available tool this is a
tool from a company called uh idbs it
was originally developed by infrasense
and it's a tool called clinical sense
and what I'm going to do is show you a
brief video uh right now that may stop
um and this video is actually a video
that will take you through selecting a
cohort of patients uh by U stepping
through essentially what are pivot
tables selecting that cohort and then
taking that cohort and projecting it
then onto genomic data calling up other
information like a k Meer curve so I may
stop you uh stop the video before the K
Meer curve comes up but I want to show
you this because for us this was really
a key element in making genomic data
useful and usable to our end users whose
primary use case was can I look at
genomic and clinical data together and
Define a cohort because the fundamental
queries in biology are those in which we
compare cohorts so uh I have my helper
Jen um who's going to roll the video now
so Jen can you set that
going this is like the wizard of eyes
I'm just the little voice that appears
and the real magic happens behind
me
for
a cohort by selecting a variety of
demographic uh data points and taking
that information and then uh looking at
a comparison between two cohorts and
looking at two uh
uh single nucleotide polymorphism or
stip markers and then looking to see
whether or not those cohorts um H had
differences in overall survival based on
those Snips so it's a very easy
application but IT addresses a lot of
the questions that users had for the
data and in fact when we um rolled this
out it was in a lot of ways very
revolutionary because although the
functionality seems simple the
procedures in place for getting access
to data to be able to make these kinds
of query varies in most Hospital Systems
is Arcane at best that uh one of the the
challenges that we've really seen uh in
in trying to do population level studies
is that one often has to go to multiple
different data managers actually fill
out paper forms ask for access to data
have people retrieve data from the
databases and then you have to in many
cases manually mix and match different
data sets to Simply link together
genomic data and and clinical data or
different demographic traffic pieces of
information and so it becomes a real
challenge uh and what a system like this
allowed study design to do is to go from
weeks or months to minutes uh where
somebody could simply look and ask
whether or not there's a big enough
population now someone sent in a
question and asked about data security
and um the the data security question is
actually one you have to really think
about carefully uh as I mentioned
earlier this data is identifiable so at
every step in the process one of our
major concerns is how we Safeguard
patient patient confidentiality do we
think about encryption how do we think
about encryption how do we protect data
and information behind our firewall and
those are absolutely things that have to
be part of um our consideration as we
put a system like this together I
mentioned that what you want to do is
present the information to the local
community by that I mean the research
Community um in 2009 I was funded as
part of a large Consortium for something
we call the lung genomics research
Consortium or
lgrc and this was a project looking at
pulmonary disease so chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease or COPD and interal
lung disease or I there was a project in
which we had data being generated on a
set of well annotated uh samples with a
tremendous uh amount of clinical data
associated with them um those samples
were actually selected sent to a central
location at the University of Pittsburgh
medical center scientists there
extracted RNA and DNA sent it out to
five other labs around the country and
we had as many as six different data
types generated on each one of those 400
samples uh so whole genome snip profiles
whole genome expression data on arrays
RNA seek small RNA seek um whole genome
methylation data on charm arrays and for
a limited number of patients exom
sequence data our job was to collect all
that data in a central location and make
it accessible and as we started to do
that we realized uh that if we're going
to make the data available and
accessible we had to do that by
considering our users in distinct use
cases and we realized there were two
broad classes of users the first was a
group of users like me computational
scientists quantitative scientists um
whose use case was very simple their use
case was John you're an idiot just give
me the data so I can analyze it the
right way but even for them the data was
so laun they didn't want it all they
wanted to be able to go in and actually
select a subset of the data so what we
built was something akin to an
e-commerce shopping site you could go in
load up a bundle and download the data
directly so you could have access to
that data and information and then do
your own analysis you could select by
data type you could select by a cohort
you define it was really designed to
allow people to rapidly get to
manageable data sets that they could
then have uh access to um and what the
system allowed us to do was to control
access to those data by uh providing a
level of security and authent
authentication for each person logging
in and for logging every transaction
that happened so we know who had what
data set to make sure we at least
provided some accounting of how the data
was used most basic biologists though
were interested in different types of
questions and one of the questions they
almost invariably asked was across
different populations tell me about my G
or pathway of interest and one of the
things we tried to do in building this
resource was every time somebody asked a
question we wanted to give them
something back so if I asked about a
gene if I started to type in a gene name
it would do text complete on the left
hand side of the screen what you can
actually see is annotation for the
individual genes including Pathways and
go terms and in Pro domains and as soon
as I start to type in a name and select
something those metadata collapse to the
relevant metadata for my particular G so
if I want to rapidly zoom in on a
pathway I can type in an index Gene get
that pathway and then pull up all the
genes that's sit in that pathway but
once I have a gene then what I do is I
get information back almost immediately
so I I present the users back with
things like um gene expression levels in
this case RNA seek data and this is RNA
seek data as fpkm value so it's not
identifiable but summary level data that
at least shows them expression levels
and what you can see is we have Mr
expression here we also have charmay
data where they can look at different
measures on those genes and see
something uh pathways are just
collection of genes so we have similar
tools um clinical data we realized
people wanted to look at the clinical
data we had and develop cohorts so we
implemented a version of that tool I
showed you earlier the clinical sense
tool from infr sense but then once we
have cohorts defined what we do is allow
um users to compare cohorts and uh we
know that most users trust people like
me to select at least a rational tool
for doing most analysis so we looking at
the GS data we had plink for looking at
G expression data we had limma followed
by gsca we try to make rational choices
so that what we could do is allow users
to Define cohorts and then contrast
those cohorts across every single data
type we had um and then we built in
other tools that allow them to get
access to the data in interesting ways
including uh just ways to take sets of
genes and do comparison
but we wanted to make it easy um
intuitive and graphically driven because
what we came to really understand very
clearly is that's something our users
wanted needed and we wanted to make take
um access to the data out of the hands
of the high priests right the the
statisticians and computational
biologists and uh we wanted to make this
gutenberg's um uh Bible in the sense
that we could take this data that was
only accessible to um select few the
high priests and really give everybody
the opportunity uh to speak directly to
the gods who lived inside the data uh we
also recognized that part of that was
engaging corporate partners and it was
really our understanding that we wanted
to find the best tools so some of the
development I talked about was funded by
a grant from Oracle uh to build this
integrated clinical and research data
warehouse we learned a lot including the
fact that um structur relational
databases aren't really best position to
handle a lot of high dimensional genomic
data uh we partnered with idbs to create
some of those data portals I showed you
we've worked with alumin on a variety of
different projects we've had
relationships over the years with
companies like Ingenuity CLC bio and
other software vendors to support the
people on our end who are the consumers
of genomic data we realize that even
though we're computational biologists we
don't always produce the best most
userfriendly tools and if our goal is to
serve our users we have to swallow our
pride sometimes and work with the people
who are developing some really high
class tools we've also built
Partnerships with other people who are
interested in really entering entering
the personal genomic space um and uh
have been Partners in developing
different aspects of the entire
ecosystem we've put in place uh one of
the things we realized we have to do is
enable research beyond our own so at Dan
Farber uh in 2009 we launched something
called the Center for concer Cancer
computational biology um that was
initially me with uh Mick who is our
associate director late last year yayu
Wong took over as associate director uh
and what we've been doing at the cccb is
really providing broad-based support for
the analysis and interpretation of uh
omic data in the context of dise and
it's really large data we've dealt with
other data types like um text mining of
uh notes fields and
emrs and uh other big data questions and
problems but our goal is to provide
broad-based support here at Dana farbor
across the Harvard campus for scientists
across Boston and I can tell you we've
worked with people around the world our
model is actually a simple one and it's
one we found that works really well we
run this like a professional Consulting
service so you come in you meet with us
we an uh we analyze your problem we
develop a work plan we present you with
a time and materials quote so here's how
long we think the project is going to
take and here's how much it will cost
and then one once you decide you want to
work with us we actually execute on that
model and we deliver data and
information back to uh the end users in
ways they can consume it we actually
offer uh support for it infrastructure
so we build websites and hosted data and
information for people and uh we provide
sequencing as a service so the whole
goal is really to try to build a
resource that allows us to support users
and I can tell you we're supporting
people uh who work here who have worked
here uh and users who find us really
from around the world so this has been
uh a really useful model and I'd be
happy to talk to people or share
information about how we've done that um
for anybody who's interested but the
real goal for us in doing all of this is
to try to conduct research and so I'm
going to take you pretty rapidly through
this research story and I apologize for
the speed at which I'm going to move to
it through it but I realize that um you
know we have only 15 minutes left and so
I blame technology for slowing us down
but I'm going to tell you a story a
little bit of a story and it starts with
a project we uh got involved with a few
years ago that involved uh uncovering
hidden subtypes and disease and this is
really a major problem in a lot of
diseases we've seen it very clearly in
cancer I got a note this says I can take
a little longer than the hour so maybe
I'll run over uh but um one of the the
the things we've been interested in
doing is um comparing different cancer
subtypes different cancer um disease
States and one challenge in doing that
is that we don't fully understand the
complexity of the disease we're really
starting to recognize that diseases are
heterogeneous and a NIC example of this
is probably breast cancer one of my
favorite papers in the entire field of
genomic uh medicine is Chuck frau's
paper on um the discovery of subtypes in
breast cancer and it was really an
eloquent An Elegant study uh an an
eloquent presentation in the paper of
how one could take genomic data and
discover new subtypes based on genomic
profiles so um that has really become a
paradigm in understanding disease
because if we analyze all breast cancer
as a single monolithic disease one thing
that becomes very clear very quickly is
that there's a confounding effect that
occurs and that in fact uh we really end
up looking at in many cases the major
subtype and and Miss signals in the
minor subtypes unless we account for
those and analyze those separately so
the project I want to describe is the
one in which we worked with ovarian
cancer uh ovarian cancer is a major
killer it's the fourth most common
cancer in women it's actually one of the
most uh one with the the greatest
fatality rate and it's really due to the
fact that this disease is one that
rapidly becomes chemotherapy resistant
in large part because the disease is
detected late when it's already highly
metastic and uh the the tumors are
evolving very very quickly so this is
actually a project that we did in
collaboration with alumina my colleagues
here were Joyce Lou uh Michelle uh
Hirsch and Ursula malonis um who worked
with us on the clinical side and they
provided us with a set of samples that
include a that included 132 very well
annotated um form six paraffin embedded
samples we profiled these on an early
version of alumina's uh Dazzle array um
I I won't comment on Dazzle today but I
will say that the Dazzle array we used
was very
reproducible uh and provided very high
quality data um and we then took the
data and Stefan benk who worked with me
applied a technique which I'll describe
in a minute called Isis to find what we
described as robust bipartitions in the
data uh we then took those and actually
analyzed them and one of the major
subtypes we found was one associated
with the expression of angiogenesis gene
we cerated all the published gene
expression data to validate the the
separation in subtypes we found in the
signature and we've also found other
subtypes we've um were in the process of
describing in other Publications but
really the the major one I'm going to
focus on today is this angiogenic
subtype so Isis is a really interesting
idea was developed by um a group in
Germany that Stefan had worked with and
the idea is very simple you take your
data and you randomly particip data into
different
subsets and then you take um all the
genes in the in the data set and you do
a statistical test comparing the gene in
one sub set and his expression levels in
the other subset and as we do that what
we find invariably is that no matter how
we split the data there are always some
genes that support that bipartition the
separation of the data into two
pieces but if we look at the data
critically what we re recognize is that
while in any split in any separation of
the data at the patient groups into two
subgroups we can find some significant
genes for a real separation we should
find many genes and if we look at that
the the uh overall number of genes that
we find that are statistically
significant we should find a larger
number in a real bipartition so
essentially what Isis does is it
randomly partici uh partitions the group
into different subsets it does this
statistical task it takes the top 100
genes and uses Fisher rule for combining
P values and comes up with a summary
statistic that we think of as the
goodness of separation or the goodness
of split so Stefon did this and I
apologize the colors have um changed
here what we found was one very robust
bipartition of the data it was actually
also supported by micro RNA expression
data that we had on the same samples and
what you can see here is that separation
of the data into a large subtype which
is about 2third of the data and a
smaller subtype about oneir of the data
and the difference between these
subtypes was really driven by the
expression of genes associated with
angiogenesis so we look back at our data
set and we asked for our data set is
there a difference in overall survival
and if you can see the C Meer curve on
the bottom it's a little faint but U the
lower subtype the yellow one is actually
this enic subtype and um it in fact is
statistically significantly different I
mentioned this was supported by data on
micr rnas and I'm not going to talk
about in any great detail um it's
described in the paper we published but
then we went to other data sources so we
took our data and uh the irony was that
publishing this paper was something that
took us nearly two years we kept on
submitting it and people initially said
well it's just another subtype how well
supported is it and we've invested a lot
of time and methods for producing robust
biomarkers so um what we did was we
amassed more and more data and
eventually the tcga data was available
we spent a couple months cleaning that
data and by the time this paper was
finally accepted we were able to
identify nearly 1,100 highgrade late
stage serus tumors and what we saw is
this pattern continue with about
onethird of the patients falling into
the angiogenic subtype 2third falling
into the non geogenic subtype and the
separation and survival became more
statistically significant I mean it's
bad in all of these patients but it's
more statistically significant um than
it was for our data set then in fact we
took all published ovarian cancer data
not just um the original 129 uh not just
the the Cirrus tumors which was what was
represented in our 129 patients that we
used to derive the signature and in fact
we saw this trend continue in an
increase statistic significance in in
Captain Meer curvs what was really
interesting about this for us was that
there were clinical trials underway in
which patients were randomized to
treatment with or without an
anti-angiogenic therapies and the
reports in literature and from people
involved in these studies is that in the
treatment arm those patients receiving
anti-angiogenic therapies about
one-third of those respond so at this St
it's numerology but it's highly
suggestive and in fact there's a trial
underway now at Dana Farber where
they're randomizing patients but also
doing gene expression profiling and our
goal in in analyzing the data that's
being generated is going to be to see
whether or not we could have predicted
with some high degree of confidence who
poost talk the responders and
non-responders to this anti-angiogenic
therapy work if we can demonstrate that
we can do that then we actually have a
clinically relevant subtype that we can
use uh in the next generation of trials
to uh assign patients to a treatment
that's most appropriate so this paper
was actually or this U work was actually
described in a paper that was published
in uh plus one I don't know 2011 but
it's easy to find um so what I I really
want to talk about is the overall idea
of using this to build different network
models so I'm going to take you through
this and I apologize that I'm going to
run over time a little bit but this is
the stuff that's really cool and
exciting so bear with me
um why we care about Network should be
obvious to anybody on this call or at
least I hope it is that we see
biological processes are not driven by
individual genes but rather by networks
of genes our goal is to understand
relationships in those networks and to
use uh genomic data which has largely
been expression data to really deduce
the patterns and relationships that
exist um that allow us to translate how
these genes are expressed into how these
genes influence the cellular phenotypes
that we observe so a lot of my thinking
about this is actually influenced by my
training in physics and um it it really
speaks to the way we think about
building and evaluating models so what
we'd like to be able to do in biology is
develop a theory that describes the
interactions that drive biological
systems the instantiation of that theory
should be a model and that model should
describe the interactions that we'd like
to be able to understand in physics we
realize there are two broad pillars that
support scientific inquiry Theory and
experiment but that often the theory is
so complex it's hard to relate back to
experimental observations so we also
recognize a third branch of physics we
call phenomenology that sort of sits
squarely between Theory and experiment
and in phenomenology what we try to do
is use empirical data to build models
that are consistent with the theory
although not directly derived from it
and in building models and biological
systems that's exactly what we've tried
to do to build models that are
consistent with our theoretical
understanding but may not be derived
from the theory directly and the reason
this is important is that as we try to
build these models what it allows us to
do is subtly shift away from a question
which I can honestly tell you I have
absolutely no idea how to answer which
is if I bu the model is this model right
because I can tell you that any model we
build is probably not right and I I well
I'll even talk about why I don't think I
can answer that question but the really
important question that we want to ask
is is this model useful now I lost it
the question is there is this model
useful the reason I can't answer the
question whether the model's right is
that we're increasingly coming to
understand that these Network models
rewire themselves as disease States
develop there we go so that if I look at
a network that I mind consider right and
let's even assume we can Define that the
normal network of interactions that
occur in a normal tissue as a disease
develops and progresses those
interactions change and when I draw one
of these ball and stick diagrams and I'm
showing you the set of
interactions what I'm always assuming
when I draw that is that each
interaction is unique and distinctive
but I can tell you the elements in this
diagram the balls which are
proteins those proteins have no innate
intelligence they do not understand what
they're going to bind to and they'll
basically bind to anything that has an
appropriate Motif so if I turn one of
their binding Partners off but turn on
something else that they can stick to
they will bind to that potentially
activate it influence behavior they'll
create a new network with a different
set of connections and so the
fundamental problem in asking is this
model
right is that the model that's right in
normal tissue may not be the model
that's right in disease tissue or the
model that's right in one disease
subtype may not be the model that's
right in another disease subtype so what
we really wanted to do is to try to
think about these subtypes in the ways
that we could interpret them and to
understand differences in the network
topology so one of the things my group
did for a while was working on Daisy and
networks and that slide probably didn't
need to be here uh but one of the things
we've come to recognize is that in
building networks and this is something
that um uh Amir Jabari and I published
on in 2009 describing a basy network
application that one way to really help
her find the queries we wanted to make
or the models we wanted to build was to
use prior sources of information and so
what I'm going to describe to you is an
approach that uh uh Kimberly glass is
really the lead done this project a very
talented post-doctoral fellow working
with me another faculty member
GCU uh who's her commentor and a
colleague and collaborator C Curtis
huttenhower developed and it's based on
the idea of modeling what happs happens
in in transcription in order for a gene
to be turned on proteins called
transcription factors have to bind
within the genome and activate the
assembl uh assemblage of a a
transcriptional uh machinery involving
RNA polymerase and that that creates uh
the mechanism by which RNA is actually
transcribed from the DNA or uh
transcribed from the DNA so as we
thought about modeling this what we
wanted to do is actually use an idea
that developed out of information Theory
called message passing and the idea is
actually really simple it relies on the
fact that we have transcription factors
and they're Downstream targets okay and
information is going to flow from the
transcription factor to its Target
but for that information to flow both
the transcription factor and its Target
have to be active and able to
participate in that flow of
communication so I'm talking hopefully
to someone out there and as I talk to
you if I were to give you a quiz at the
end of this presentation and ask you
what you remembered about message
passing if you took that quiz and scored
100% we would know that both you and I
did our jobs in passing information back
and forth that I told you what you
needed to know and you weren't checking
email or doing something else that you
were actually listening carefully okay
so as I pass information to you I have
to do my job but you have to do your job
and if you get 100% we both did our job
but if you fail nobody other than you or
me would be able to uh understand why
communication broke down is it that
you're checking email I'm not paying
attention or is that I'm talking about
my summer vacation instead of talking
about message passing so what we can do
is really model that mathematically by
creating mathematical functions we call
the responsibility and availability and
we can try to fit those but for a very
simple Network we can't do that but if
we have a much more complex Network
right if I give a quiz to everybody
listening to this presentation and if
most people get 70 or 80 or 90% % but
two or three people people fail
miserably then the most likely
conclusion is that I've done my job in
transmitted information but that not
everybody received it and so we can
actually build a model like this
recognizing that with the whole genome
sequence we can look at transcription
factors we can take those transcription
factors and use them to Define an
initial Network and we can take that
Network and then use other sources of
data and information
to refine it by calculating iteratively
the responsibility and availability and
eventually fitting it to the appropriate
am okay so what we did was we took Panda
and we applied it to ovarian cancer data
and we used the biggest data set we had
it was 510 ovarian cancer uh patients
for whom we had gene expression data in
the tcga database what we did was we
normalized that data we assigned it to
uh each patient to an individual subtype
using the model we described in that
paper and what we found was that about
onethird of the patients fell into this
angiogenic subtype we then used an
algorithm called Panda uh which has been
described in a paper uh where Kimberly
glass was the first author in plus one
and what Panda does is it fits this kind
of message passing Network model so
what's really interesting about is we
took these data we used the motif data
set priers we built networks and then we
compared the networks and the key thing
in comparing these networks is that what
we were able to do was uh to look at
these networks not based on the
individual genes but rather to look at
the edges because remember what we're
seeing in these networks is that they
rewire and the atom of that rewiring is
not the genes themselves but the
connections the networks so we're
looking at how information flows and
we're seeing the information being
rerouted in different disease sometimes
okay so we can capture that by looking
at the edges and the probability these
edges are real and we can look at the
Target genes and their overlap and the
reason we default back to the genes even
though I've spent uh the last minute or
two persuading you the edges are
important is that the genes provide a
basis for which we can interpret what's
happening and what's interesting is we
look at the disease date what we see is
that in many cases a lot of the same
genes are targeted
but they're targeted in different
ways in different subtypes and that's
going to be an important part of the
message I'm going to tell so every
Network paper has to have one of these
um Fireworks diagrams and what we
focused on were the 10 transcription
factors that you can see here in big
gray balls um that represent those that
seem to change the most between the
angiogenic and non-angiogenic
subtypes so this is the angiogenic
subtype in red this is the
non-angiogenic subtype in blue and if
you actually look at this carefully you
can probably see the Network's changing
and you may be able to see it most
easily in the upper right hand corner
where you see a lot of connections in
the non-angiogenic network and fewer
Connections in the angiogenic network
but believe me uh there are real changes
here I'm going to show you a different u
Way of representing this data that
Kimberly developed um actually in the
next slide and it's something that uh I
always call called the spirro graph but
kimby really likes these uh then what
she does is she represents the
transcription factors around the center
and then they're targets around the
outside and one of the really
interesting things you start to see in
this representation which I'm growing
more and more fond of is the fact that
there's some transcription factors that
seem more active in the angiogenic
subtype shown here in the center in red
there's some that are more active
meaning they have more Connections in
the non-androgenic subtype shown here in
the center in blue but they're actually
complex combinatorial patterns of
regulation for particular genes that are
not unique to one some type or the other
so if we look at these key transcription
factors these 10 in the center of that
Circle what we find is that for each one
of them we can make some kind of an
association with um gene expression data
with um we can make some kind of
association with the disease pheny but
what's really interesting is if we look
at their patterns of
expression in most most instances we
don't see a significantly different
pattern of the expression of these
transcripts but if we look at their
targets what we do see is actually
patterns of differential expression that
correlate with patterns of methylation
and in fact the the the representation
here is skewed a little bit but one of
the really interesting things we see if
I look at this upper panel that says PF
differential expression the transcript I
factor
itself uh for the second column which is
a
d3a the transcription Factor itself
isn't differentially expressed but its
targets really are and that's reflected
in methylation data with a transcription
factor is not differentially methylated
between States but its Downstream
targets are and so this is a really
interesting observation for us that the
transcription factors weren't changing
but their influence
was right so if we were to look for
these transcription factors using G
expression data we would never find them
but the network models actually point us
to these transcription factors being
important so what it also suggests is
there complex regulatory patterns that
occur and what we try to do is to
classify genes based on whether they
seem to be uh more highly activated in
the angiogenic subtype or the
non-angiogenic subtype and whether they
more highly targeted in the angiogenic
or non-angiogenic
subtit so we defined these Gene groups
and then began to look at whether or not
those Gene groups were relevant to
understanding the angiogenic process and
again invariably what we found was that
we could link the gene groups back to
processes that were known to be
associated with angiogenesis and in
particular in this left hand column here
shown above and in the heat map what we
found was a strong degree of
significance between those genes which
were targeted and upregulated in the
antigenic network and and and the
angiogenic subtype and processes we know
are associated with
angiogenesis but we also saw these
complex regulatory patterns where
multiple uh transcription factors
interacted to begin to produce
um Downstream effects and then in fact
we looked shown here in the off at the
likelihood that these transcription
factors would occur uh co-occur in a
regulatory pattern uh by chance we found
that we were seeing them at a frequency
that was far far greater than we'd
expect by chance so there's a
statistically significant uh enhancement
of particular co-regulatory processes
that we would see and what was
interesting about these is these
processes actually suggest potential
therapeutic intervention
and so by looking at these we're able
actually to look to the literature and
suggest different therapies that might
be useful so these are detailed here
we're actually um uh have a paper that's
submitted that describes these but what
was most interesting about is while we
didn't have the opportunity to validate
these in a set of laboratory models what
we were able to do is actually find
support for uh these different um
associations in the literature and in
fact indications that in ovarian cancer
models and other models uh that these um
that these uh therapies and the
interventions were actually uh
potentially actionable and so in a paper
we submitted we actually show uh a
number of different studies with gene
expression data available and what's
probably most interesting is the fourth
one down which is a a a study that
involved gene expression analysis of er
positive breast tumors that were treated
with a drug that's shown to have some
anti-angiogenic um activity and the
interesting thing shown in this heat map
uh to the right is that for the six
different classes of genes that are
regulated we saw a response pattern
that's exactly what we would have
predicted if we look back at our Network
model okay so uh we're very excited
about this I have a few more slides um
that I would show if I had more time and
about an approach we've been using to
try to generalize this to individual
patients uh but I've gone on for a long
time I just want to say that Matt Tong
and Timberly have really come up with a
very interesting approach to try to
build Network models for individual
samples and in the case of applications
to Medical Systems individual patients
uh but they're starting to show us a lot
about the way in which these networks
act and function um and we've applied it
to looking at diseases like breast
cancer to try to understand whether we
can identify even more uh subtypes from
the disease the last thing I want to
mention is we want to communicate the
mission back to the community um if I
had time out that if and if I trusted um
this system not to Crash by showing a
video um I would uh ask uh Jen to show
the video but I'm not going to do that
uh but uh if you go to our long genomics
research Consortium website you'll see
um a website that we designed we
actually invest did about one half of 1%
of our budget we hired a web development
team we hired a a science writing team
to interview the scientist and develop
uh really concise descriptions of the
project and why it was important and
information for patients and then what
we did was we uh put this as a public
facing part of our portal and uh made it
available to really describe to the
broader Community why this work was so
of s such fundamental importance um if
you go and look at it you'll probably
realize that it's really nice and well
laid out my uh Mother's looked at it a
lot of times and my picture actually in
the animation shows up at the end uh
because we showed the scientists and the
people who Dei developed the website
worked with me and so they put me front
and center I should have been other
people on the project but you know my
mom likes to come and see my picture and
show her friends so she can be proud
look there's my son the scientist who
actually works on interesting important
thing but for us this idea of
communicating to patients is absolutely
essential and the reason this is of the
reason for this is that fundamentally
patients are the ones um that are
necessary if we're going to change the
way we approach curing disease everybody
says I want to cure disease what we're
ultimately discovering is that that I uh
that we is always the Royal we that
there are barriers to sharing the data
that if I give you my data and you
discover something I get no credit so I
have no uh incentive to share data and
what we're really starting to see is
that as patients get involved those
barriers break down so um I personally
think about the fact that I want people
to share data because my experience in
analyzing large data sets is the only
way to make this whole system work is to
have access to the most possible data
the greatest most expensive metadata to
Mak sense of of the the information that
we have available so the last point I
want to make is just that genomics is
here to stay um the short version of the
story is in 2010 I had the opportunity
uh to spend some time in Australia
working with some colleagues and friends
there and um the real story is I I went
down with my family and we arrived and
we rented a car for the 3 months we were
there I came home from the car rental
place with the keys and if your family
works like my family my wife took one
look at me and one look at the keys and
uh for the next three months uh she
drove and I rode the bus uh but I was
riding in the very next day to work with
my uh colleague she actually drove me
around quite a bit and I got to drive
there too but on a day-to-day basis
going to work I typically rode the bus
um and uh the second day I was there the
first day I was working with my
colleagues I looked up and I saw this
sign on the bus in Brisbane it said
spitting is unacceptable bus operators
are now equipped with DNA kits to assist
with the apprehension of offenders so I
realized this is a good place to do be
doing genomics science and that genomics
is increasingly a part of our everyday
lives so I open with quotes I'll quickly
close with two this is from one of my
favorite authors William Gibson he said
the future is here it's just not widely
distributed and then uh since I'm a
physicist I have to close with a quote
by physicist because you now know that
physicists are the smartest people on
Earth uh so fery said uh before I came
here I was confused about this subject
after listening to your lecture I'm
still confused that at a higher level so
there are a couple questions which I'm
going to answer for anybody who wants to
bear with me uh but um I want to thank
you all for um soldiering through um the
technical glitches we had and you're
staying a little bit longer and uh if
I've done my job you're highly confused
but I'll try to resolve that all right
so thank you I can hear the Applause um
I just want to point out this work is um
work that's been done by a really
talented group of people and supported
by a lot of different organizations my
email address is here at the top my name
is quacken Bush so if you Google me you
can find me um but if you have other
questions feel free to draw me a not all
right so uh I've had nine questions come
in some of them have actually answered
during the course of um the uh
presentation but I'll step through them
quickly the first one is do patients
know that uh well they can sent to have
their sequence analyzed they may be
exposed characteristics of their
relatives and as I pointed out earlier
informing them of that is actually an
important piece of the informed consent
and I don't think anyone has really come
to grips with what that means and
whether or not we should actually get
consent more broadly the one advantage
we sometimes have been looking at tumor
biology is that if we're looking at the
sematic genome The genome that's mutated
in the tumor there often many more
mutations so that identification and
tracing that back to a germ line is much
more difficult C that said to be honest
I think anybody's genome um uh is
potentially identifiable sematic or
germine and I think we just have to be
very careful I think we also have to
really think through uh protections
discrimination and all the issues
associated with that so it's a
challenging social ethical and legal
question uh someone else asked about how
we protect data and how we secure um the
data information prevents unauthorized
access and uh for us this has really
been uh one of the key elements in
thinking through the process there is no
absolute security but there isn't with
any data store one of the things we see
most often though is the greatest data
breaches come not from anything that we
would think about putting in place but
actually physical security that people
themselves are the weakest link and when
you look at um violations of HIPPA this
health insurance portability and
protection act patient confidentiality
requirements here in the US it's
somebody losing a laptop and a cab or
somebody um losing a flash drive um on
an airplane uh it's not somebody hacking
into a system that said when we build
our systems we really want to Ure we
have secure firewalls the data is
encrypted we control access um and we
really make sure people getting access
for the right reasons someone asked
about the lgrc website I apologize I
didn't put this up uh you can find it by
doing a Google search for lung genomics
research Consortium but uh the the URL
is actually lung
lyen genomics. org it's lyen genomics.
org the research portal is up it
actually I it may only be partially
functioning today uh because um we had a
problem actually with our security
certificate
they were trying to work out and
somebody asked if we could query for
your favorite Gene and the answer is
absolutely yes so you can easily if
things are working apply for a login get
one log in and query for genes the
cohort selector may not be working and
that was the last word I had before the
presentation someone asked does genomic
medicine need FDA approval and um the
answer
is really it depends on the application
and how you're going to use it
so uh one of the things that we've seen
time and
again is that a lot of the applications
which are uh making their way into the
practice of clinical medicine today are
those in which we're already testing for
things that could be tested using other
types of application as part of the
routine standard of care so again some
of this has to do with placing
information in context if I have a
patient who has colon cancer and I know
that patient has a
mutation then I can tell a physician
that they probably shouldn't be treated
with egfr Inhibitors because they're
unlikely to work and so in fact in the
in the the uh part of the standard of
care now for patients with colon cancer
is to test them ahead of time for these
KRA mutations to understand whether or
not they have these particular mutations
so the implementations of genomic
medicine that we're starting to see are
those in which we test uh fixed panels
of potentially clinically actionable
variants and what we report back to
Physicians are those which are known to
be clinically actionable in the disease
today okay and in that case um that
information is typically checked in that
vetted by somebody like a pathologist
who's qualified to draw those
conclusions uh because if we have
software tools doing that it starts to
become something that does need FDA
clearance but if we're providing
evidence to someone who can then provide
that guidance to someone who can
ultimately make a decision and only
providing the molecular evidence um
we're using already established tests um
and um we're we're providing guidance
back to those who are knowledgeable in
how to interpret them but you know do
you need FDA guidance and approval the
the sort of short answer is you need to
uh really look at the individual
application and understand how the data
and information is going to be used and
what the um what the ultimate goal of
your application is going to be so uh
another um listener and wow they're
quite a few uh wrote to ask what the
goal of modeling was is it to determine
appropriate estimators and
discriminators or is it to understand
something else about the system we're
looking at and again uh I apologize for
not being able to give a definitive
answer but one of the things that we've
seen so often is that the goal of
modeling really depends on what you're
trying to do so some of the modeling we
do is really focus on trying to
understand what the new subtypes some of
the modeling we do is to do patient
classification but some of the modeling
we do is to try to understand the
mechanisms associated with the distinct
genotypes we observe and so our goal in
building
models um varies between the different
projects we look at but our ultimate
goal is to capture something about the
underlying biology ology and hopefully
to capture it in a way that uh informs
us about the mechanism of disease so
that ultimately we can use that to build
better Diagnostics and better
Therapeutics another question had to be
another question
um uh is focused on from Founders and
the fact that disease is is constantly
undergoing Evolution and um that is in
fact a really important consider ation
in any of this that what we're doing is
when we're taking a snapshot of disease
by looking at a tumor biopsy that's
typically something for patients which
is uh treatment naive uh we often uh
don't know what's going to happen in
that tumor over time so we're trying to
use available Data before treatment to
predict what's going to happen and what
we really recognize is there are
limitations to that so that in the best
of all possible worlds we'd be able to
follow the evolution of the tumor Under
The Selective pressure of therapy there
are some diseases like blood-based
cancers like um lymphomas and myomas
where we can do that very easily there
are other diseases like solid tumors
where it's simply not feasible so while
I'm very excited about genomics one of
the other things I realized is that one
of the things we do with our patients
all the time is image them and there's
an emerging field called radiomics where
people try to extract high-dimensional
features from radiological dat
and I've been working with a colleague
here hubo s who's an expert in radiomics
to try to link genomic data with
radiomic data to really see if we can
use them together to build better
predictors uh that take into account the
the fact that these tumors really are
mutating and changing under selective
pressure um I um I guess the last
question was um for the lgrc website
which I think I gave and then someone
asked asked uh someone thanked me for
adding um his question so um I hope
whoever you are it answered your
question and answered answered it
appropriately I don't know what your
question is so I apologize so those are
all the questions I had you've been with
me uh for a very long period of time so
I hope this was interesting I hope it
was
informative and um I apologize for the
technical glitches I've given this
presentation in far less than an hour in
the past um so I thank you for bearing
with me and um if you have questions you
can always send me an
email
so
friends uh at bio conference is there
anything
else or is it time for us to Say Goodbye
Oh I got a standing ovation from one of
the uh the listeners so thank you again
I I've only seen two names Nam among the
question there three names among the
questions oh four names so uh to the
four of you uh thanks for taking time
out of your afternoon or evening or
morning um and uh feel free to contact
me if there's anything else all right so
have a a good rest of your day and U
hopefully we'll be able to do this
again